see you mom  not one of these nice to good levers we  sexy  I like you a lot  your brother fell asleep in homeroom  this morning with a third time in the  past week where's mom someone keeps on  coming over her her name is Diane what  did you say  alright mom  hey you want to talk about it hey I'm  sleeping with the lights on every time I  turn them off there's this woman he  doesn't like fight I know I see her too  ah how did we wake you Mike  where is how you story long time ago I  had a friend named Diana I found out  something really bad happened to her but  you came back she's gonna stay as long  as you keep the lights out  let's go  you know I  there is a jet women in this house  everyone is afraid of the dark and  that's what she feeds on  you  woman waiting in the shadows I see her  too